[Music]
um so i'm an
asian adoptee and so one secret i have
is that sometimes i wish
that um i was never put up for adoption
or had to go through
any of the struggles that i have
[Music]
my secret is i'm depressed because the
pandemic is ending
i'm an introvert living in an extroverts
world and
i'm now allowed to take off my physical
mask but i'm gonna have to put my
other mask back on and it's kind of hard
so many don't know that but it's
tricky going back into the real world
when i'd rather
just be at home
[Music]
okay so one thing that i have kept i
guess a secret
throughout my life is that
um i actually had a child
when i was 14 years old and i adopted
him out
and no not a lot of people know that
about me
[Music]
so once upon a time i may or may have
not
did coke for my first time when i was in
high school at church
in my high school youth group and that
happened
i was on one at church and that just
tells you
how forgiving god is i guess
[Music]
i found out recently that alcoholism
runs in my family
and that's a little too accurate
to me
[Music]
i had an ex-girlfriend who
cheated on me and we stayed together
a week after i found out i cheated on
her
and never told her and we stayed
together for
another year and broke up amicably
but to this day she never knows that i
did get revenge on her and still hold it
against her
[Music]
when i was eight years old me and my mom
i went to the airport to go pick up my
dad and
a police officer just pulled us over and
without warning like pepper sprayed the
hole inside of the car
pulled my mom out beat her in front of
me
we called back up to take her away he
pulled me out of the car
threw me onto a stack of magazines in
the front of his car
and i remember ask telling him i have to
buckle my seat belt and i can't send the
front i'm too little
he said that doesn't matter and then he
sped around the block a few times
and then he just left me at the airport
and drove away
so then after that even now i still
feel like really uneasy around police
and i see like a police siren
kind of shut down a bit it's definitely
just been something
hard to talk about but i'm hoping now as
there's more of a cultural conversation
happening about
reforming the police system that
can actually start to happen
[Music]
i question my gender a lot and what
gender
even means i wonder a lot if i'd grown
up without
this like very intense like you must be
feminine thing from my very conservative
family
and all of that um what
pronouns i would use because more and
more
i definitely feel not a part of men or
women
but there's no i don't think i would
ever have it in me to actually change my
pronouns
or actually tell people like my two best
friends are sitting over there
and they have no idea and i'll probably
keep it that way for a long time
when i was four years old i had a older
cousin by two years
and uh we were on the beach and i think
our parents
were like away but i was young i was
like four i think she was like
a little bit older than me i just
remember her like
chasing me around and i just i didn't
want anything to do with her and then
she tackled me right to the ground and
like forcefully was making out with me
and i just wanted nothing with that so
yeah that's all i have to share
[Music]
so one time when i was about four or
five years old
i was sitting down in the my room of my
house
uh and i guess i was watching like
pokemon or something
and instead of going to the bathroom
like i should have because i
had known how to use the bathroom i
instead took the plastic bag out of a
small
black garbage can and proceeded to
take my underwear off and poop in there
and then roam around the room with no
pants or anything else on
[Music]
i once poured dish soap into a public
water fountain
and it poured out into the street and
they had to shut down the water fountain
[Music]
i once sneezed and farted at the same
time and tried to blame the fart on
somebody else
i have a wife and a girlfriend
[Music]
my secret share for you
i love beer so every day i drinking
via three water five water
but i tell my boyfriend i only one
bottle
every day it's my secret
thank you
[Music]
i secretly really miss my ex's dog
i always say that i hate him and i do
but i miss his dog
i check who you're following on
instagram every single
[Music]
day
my secret is i am not muslim anymore
and i became agnostic and none of my
family knows this
and i don't know how to tell them
but i feel like i need to be true to
myself so
this is the first time i say it out loud
to the world
that's my secret
i really pride myself on being
independent and free and
hardworking by myself but deep down
inside i
just want to be taken care of and be a
stay-at-home wife
and that's it
a secret i would like to share is that
to this day i'm not sure about my
sexuality and it's something that
kind of makes me feel uncomfortable even
talking about it to other people
growing up i was always questioned about
the way i st
i was standing if i was speaking not
mentally enough
if i wasn't standing manly enough as i
was if i was being a mama's boy
i never had the interest that a
regular so to speak guy would have from
where
i'm from i wasn't really into sports if
anything i was bad at it
i was never never into cars or anything
that is considered
manly enough in my culture and
uh even by people that i was raised
i was questioned and they used to say
that i was gay
because i had friends that were gay
and they questioned so much the
behavior that i was having
that they made that made me question my
own sexuality to the day
to to this day i'm not sure
what i am regarding my sexuality and
i'm not sure if i'm okay with not
knowing um
[Music]
you